welcome to this video dumb dem yen Oh
for something like that so what do we
get so yeah it's a difficult position
it's not like you have an easy choice
there I'm going for my old she goin one
advantage of the slide is that I've
played it so often but I really really
can play quickly so particularly great
as we know but it is quick it's
something that you can dash out really
quickly I think that a five is better
than a takes be five he doesn't want to
commit this yet wow that's a funny woman
trading trading my worst piece thank you
okay
gasps strategically speaking this is
really bad why would you trade my worst
piece now maybe I could have played a
five at some point yeah this type of
position usually gives white exactly
nothing not even in situations where he
has not traded the dark squared bishop
but with dark squared bishop traded
simply nothing many end games in fact
are pretty good for black because of f5
coming so I'm just aiming for for
trading trading stuff and play this end
game yeah don't even mind the Queen
trade but the special is somewhat it's a
bit under pressure now maybe I am back
into him check yeah I mean okay maybe
maybe I'm I should take if I try to play
for a win which of course I want to do
hmm man it's not really doing much maybe
Queen here so I'm not quite sure
check this net wide so much i will go
king of eight King King e7 and 97 90 s
to go back
yeah it tries to bring the night to a 3
i'm going to check the pawns but I get
roots traded now and that usually means
the end of any white ideas and then as
that I have some ideas ok really so kind
of surprised that he can you go with
their maybe take stakes 98 text eggs 98
98 2nite be seven and I'm winning this
pawn or not i think im just winning this
porn so let's go down
that's a pawn try to get rid of this
yeah so it seems that the Sun would
fashion line claims another victim
people often really have problems in
those super slow boring positions and
make all kinds of bad strategic
decisions here it was the trade of the
dark squared bishop and after that well
rookie it was the liquid of course but
after that it got God was quite a
quitclaim so night them made a form I
think I just bring the King around and
try to play before
okay let's block this down to 196
trading or getting p form plate
check
yeah i mean i can really play this in a
quick way it's a good good good thing
about the line I've played this so often
can really get a huge time edge check
white forfeits on time no yeah so there
are a couple of things the move Bishop
g5 was really weird my bishop only seven
is clearly the worst piece that I have
Michael Bishop g5 okay I'm happily
trading and this is um yeah after dark
squared bishop Tsar traded nothing much
happens white can try to do what he did
you open the file and so on but you're
not really getting any invasion invasion
going that is it son nothing's chalice
is happening going back here it equals
back and I Go Go Cade and now he has to
take yes so just take and something like
this happens and I had this end game
quite often even in blitz chess my usual
ideas to go Knight b6 and try to play a
five at some point I feel that this is
somewhat easier for black to play in
some scenarios there are P sacrifice on
C form to get two pawns from white but
this is not happening anymore after them
bishops have been traded and so on but
here he can definitely hold yeah i can
play something like g4 and it will be
will be very equal ish it's not i cannot
really do much I can try I can play
Knight f7 over low to e7 and yeah
triumph to f7 over to e7 player 5 and so
on but it's still probably about equal
but this is not working he just drops
the poem and now this end games when you
for black yeah this is it's not such a
terrible line but wyd playing a five at
an earlier stage i think is much more
much more threatening okay thanks for
watching